hi there steve kaufman here
and today i want to talk about why i
learn languages and i want to use as an
example
persian which is what i'm learning right
now if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notifications if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a review
so
uh if any of you read my book the
linguist a personal guide to language
learning
uh
you will remember that i
always get interested in the history the
culture
countries that influence other countries
how countries are an amalgamation of
different
influences and and peoples and that's
been the history of the world and that's
what kind of motivates me to learn
languages and learn about all these
different cultures and so forth persian
is no exception i'm very lucky that i
have a person tutor collaborator in iran
who has created tremendous content for
me on the history of iran foods of iran
has interviews with ordinary people in
iran so i have a bit of a smattering of
that background but as with when we
learn languages and we learn and forget
words things that i learn about the
history of a country i tend to forget
them as well but every time i forget
them something remains and so my
appreciation of of the history does
improve a little bit each time but it
gives me a basis from which to learn
more things and so right now
at link
i am doing a series of four episodes of
a podcast about iranian identity put out
by this podcast service called epitome
dot ir or epitome books dot ir i'll
leave a link to the to the uh podcast in
the description box it's all in uh
in farsi and persian of course
and so
i am
just enjoying so much participating in
this series of discussions
uh and the narrator quotes different
books
where
the question of iranian identity is
discussed so i have this sort of
sensation
that i'm participating in a discussion
amongst iranians about their identity
and through that i am exposed to aspects
of their history
some of which is new to me some of which
i have already been exposed to and so
the whole experience to me is is my
reward that's why i learn languages to
be able to do that kind of thing and
i've done it in ukrainian when my
ukrainian tutor sent me material on
ukrainian history i've done it in polish
when i went to this website and found
audio books and ebooks about polish
history these are the things that i'm
interested in czech the tolkie
czesco minilosti about czech history
those that's what drives me to learn
languages but let's get back to persian
and i also wanted to comment on persian
because someone asked me here
on my youtube channel
what has been my reaction to learning
persian well
first of all there are a lot of iranian
immigrants in vancouver and just the
yesterday or the night before we were at
a restaurant low and behold families
sitting beside us are recent immigrants
i don't know how recent but from iran
the iranians respond so positively when
you speak to them in their language it's
astounding and they also immediately ask
you are you familiar with
persian poetry and of course because
poetry is very important to the iranians
but it's too difficult for me so i
disappoint them when i say no
but very often too they'll ask me if i
speak turkish because
1 in 5 or 18 or whatever percent 15 of
iranians are of azeri turk origin so
therein we begin to see that there's
this historical connection between turks
and
persians or iranians
now but the the interesting thing what i
find so fascinating is is in this
series of of episodes about
iranian identity
if we go back 2500 years
to the emperor the the empire of of uh
cyrus and and i think the greatest
extent of the persian empire was under
darius the great i don't remember
because i forget it all but
the the old uh accede or however it's
pronounced
empire
was two-thirds non-iranians
uh if we look at a map it included you
know at various times greece and and
maybe the northern part of india and you
had turkic people there and of course
originally
you had the elamites and the acadians
because
ancient persia included
what is today iraq
it included
you know the fertile crescent from which
the abrahamic religions came
eventually islam but initially
uh judaism and christianity
so
right off the bat
it was a multi-ethnic multi-lingual
empire and so what was the identity at
that point of course there are people
guess at it but apparently herodotus the
greek
historian
said that people who identified as
persian parse or whatever term was used
they had certain advantages over
non-persians within that empire so
obviously there was a sense of persian
identity at that time
uh when maced alexander the great of
macedonia invaded he tried to bring in
greeks and make iran more greek which
didn't really please the locals who
preferred their persian identity so
there was some kind of persian identity
the persians also had their own religion
the zoroastrian religion which was
essentially the the state religion
uh as near as as we can tell so there's
this identity as part of the
the uh akameniid or hahemaneshion empire
which included many ethnic groups
cyrus in his great constitution was
very
say magnanimous but very tolerant of
different religions and different
different ethnic groups
and maybe he had no choice because they
were
they outnumbered the persians in his
empire
so there was that and then after
alexander the great
the greeks under
i i think i might have said it wasn't
alexander who tried to
bring in greeks and make iran more greek
it was seleucus
who celeukus or however it's pronounced
who
basically as the
uh
massive the alexander's empire was split
he ended up with
iran basically and he tried to make it
more greek which didn't work but after a
few hundred years there was once again
an iranian
dynasty an iranian control of their
country
and so there is now this obviously there
was a sense of identity as iranians
through the language through their
zoroastrian uh religion
uh through a sense of where they lived
through identity with identifying with
the ruler
i don't know they even had a flag they
had certain things that represented
identity for them
uh
and then
passing through my
forgetfulness
uh you know you had the uh what we call
the the parthian empire i think which uh
goes under a different name in persian
which i've forgotten and then the
sasanian period where iran was fighting
with rome all the time and eventually
the arab invasion and islam was
introduced so now we have islam so
there's identity through language
identity through territory identity
through this persian ethnicity which for
a long time was a minority
you know
group within the greater
persian empire
and now we have identity through
religion
and the religion was
mostly sunni
and
and then around the 10th 11th century
we have a series of turkish
dynasties
in iran
and so the
again i'm going from memory but as i
read it i enjoy it and then i forget it
but so arab was the arabic language was
perhaps more prestigious through
religion but eventually the
basically the education standards in
in iran were higher than amongst the
arab conquerors and so
persian had a
pride of place in the administration and
so forth but then the turks came in and
they
tended to speak turkish in the court and
then at a certain point perhaps
coinciding with the mongol invasions
there was a revival of
uh the farsi or persian language so
there was again
you can sense through all of that as
this person quotes the different sources
debating about you know what represented
the iranian identity and so forth
uh
that
there was a revival of the persian
language
and then with the
safavid
dynasty
the shia religion is established as the
national religion and so now we have an
identity
so we have a islamic identity we have a
shia identity as opposed to the sunni
ottoman empire uh we have of course that
iranian identity so you have this
accumulation of different identities and
getting back to the poetry
uh which i always get asked about
the sort of
one of the main periods of flowering of
poetry in iran was during the time that
the mongols i think initially the turks
again are going from memory and then the
mongols and the ilhans
dynasties and so there was this
flowering of poetry which
focused to a large degree
on
you know
myths and traditions and and and the
history of the great flowering of the
persian empire back 2500 years ago so
the iranians have been imbued with this
sense of their identity which consists
of all these different
elements
and depending on which iranian you speak
to he may identify or she may identify
more with the period prior the greatness
of the you know persian empire or more
may identify more with
um you know islam
and so forth so there's there's an inc
and even today as i said mentioned
earlier there's this ethnic mixture in
iran you have azeri turks you have
turkmens who are small number but were
very influential initially
in
some of the dynasties that were
established you have kurds you have
arabs
and then you have various uh sort of
nomad groups so there's quite a variety
of peoples within iran and so probably
today
the identity is one of iran as a nation
the country of iran
with all of the ethnic
you know minorities that they have
and in this um series
it is pointed out that amongst the
people in the middle east the iranians
have a much stronger sense of national
identity you know are you proud of being
an iranian and so a much higher
percentage in iran will say yes i am
whereas in places like jordan or egypt
apparently the identification is more
with islam and less with the country so
all of this is interesting
the fact that i'm able to read and
listen to all of this information and
kind of
span the period from 2500 years ago to
today
and try and picture
iraq when it was part of iran and or
persia and now and stuff
is to a large extent due to sahara and
her ability to create material for me
and find stuff for me i wish i could
find someone to do the same for arabic
arabic
as a whole
or
you know egypt or or north africa or
the levant you know syria lebanon
palestine and so forth so because that
to me is the fun of language learning is
is exploring
through language
history culture people
and so i'm very grateful to sahara and i
enjoy doing this in persian and i will
certainly be looking forward to doing it
in arabic and in other languages
moving forward
so
there you have it i will leave you with
a couple of videos on this issue of
language and culture and i'd be
interested in your own reactions and how
you deal with
and to what extent you're attracted to
the idea of learning about culture and
history through language thanks for
listening bye for